nick jonas and priyanka being obsessed  with each other for a minute straight  babies as many as god would give us i  love kids i always have loved kids  they're my favorite people in the planet  so like as many as i can the family's  just getting bigger and bigger and  that's a beautiful thing i didn't know  he was the one he was tornado that kind  of just took over my life and i just  kind of went with it i have a lot of  faith in who my husband is he's obsessed  with you as it should be the good news  is that we both really enjoy talking to  each other which i think is probably  important for me somebody we have a rule  we always we don't go beyond like a week  and a half of not seeing each other i  think we settled into our roles as  husband and wife like fairly quickly  it's actually really annoying but  he insists on looking at my face when i  wake up it's amazing and super sweet  that's what you want your husband to do  but it's also like a little awkward  okay